okay my name is Doreen I just graduated
I was a salon fella 2018 I came here
from Zimbabwe and I did an independent
study with Angela Shastri
so I had ten years work experience in
accounting and finance before I came to
Sloan and I had this passion for
agriculture that stemmed from growing up
in Zimbabwe with parents that were
farmers so I had done quite a bit of
research personally on on agriculture
everywhere that had worked and even
though I was working finance I tried to
kind of make sure that I did some
agriculture work whether it was majors
and acquisitions or whatever try to make
sure that I infused agriculture into my
work so when I got here I wanted to kind
of formalize this passion and you know
do a bit more in-depth analysis in-depth
research on this sector and where what I
wanted to contribute to it after
graduation so I did an independent study
titled innovations across the
agriculture value chain an opportunity
for savvy entrepreneurs because I want
to be an entrepreneur in the sector so
the independent study involved
researching kind of the parent value
chain or the traditional value chain as
it is and then interviewing different
stakeholders to figure out where
opportunities are for innovation and
that's what I worked on with Anjali
so I had I started out with some
questions that I wanted to answer or
some hypothesis and I you know and and
and the main one was the fact that there
was there's a big opportunity to do
valley edition and so to move you know
farmers from the traditional farming and
and and raw material production to
actual processing of items of consumer
goods you know whether it's juice or you
know personal care items anything that
can be produced from agricultural
produce from excess agricultural produce
so my hypothesis was that everybody on
the table kind of would agree with the
you know with the statement that that is
the only way to move farmers or rural
communities from poverty to prosperity
and that's where all the you know that's
where most of the investments should be
going forward so I started with that
question and so when I interviewed
stakeholders I interviewed farmers I
interviewed business people I
interviewed development organizations
and kind of asked questions that kind of
questioned popped on that hypothesis or
supported it and the response was
actually what what I expected which is
it's true that that is you know where
everybody thinks that the investment
should be focused on it's just a matter
of changing some existing mental models
that keep both farmers and investors in
this sector kind of stuck in in doing
things as they've always been done
I looked at all the things that I was
interested in things that I was
passionate about but that I wasn't
necessarily addressing through my MBA
classes at Sloan and so you know
agriculture stood out and then within
agriculture I kind of looked at what was
related to my startup which is you know
what I'm hoping to work on after now
that I've graduated and so you know it
was kind of easy to do to to narrow down
a topic because I wanted something that
was aligned with my startup and my
interests
managing the work and myself was
probably the most difficult I think like
I said because I had kind of done some
research on the topic without really
having you know any any plans of using
it in any formal way I thought that I
underestimated the time it would take to
actually come up with something
meaningful and so and I I you know I
like to talk about people person so I
enjoyed the interviewing part and I mean
I kept gathering information and
gathering information and talking to
people more than the people I had on my
list but then when it came to coming you
know to like kind of gathering the
insight and writing what I had done and
why I had done it and what the next
steps are it was kind of difficult and
also I had a full course load because I
spent all of my IEP doing this research
and so I didn't take any other classes
or any units that I needed towards
graduation so in the spring everything
was kind of jus the independent study
all the courses and and and all of that
so it was difficult but I mean I worked
with Anjali a lot and trying to figure
out how I needed to craft the paper and
so we did a few you know iterations of
that she actually is very hands-on so
she will take post-it notes and write
you know this safer section could be
this do you agree what are you trying to
get from there so she kind of pushed me
a bit and ask me questions that help me
figure out the structure of the paper
and also the time I would spend on each
section and what was more important and
what was less important and how I you
know like just I could show that I
actually did the work so you know
because doing the work and actually
reporting the work is quite different
but yeah in the end it worked
definitely with Anthony's help and you
know working extra hours
so I think this experience was
interesting for me because I ended up
using frameworks in in the independent
study that I think are unique to Sloane
so for example I used the I used systems
thinking which is you know obviously a
big thing here at Sloane and also kind
of things around sustainability and
sustainability oriented innovation which
is MIT which MIT is you know a champion
in so I think that being in this
environment kind of helped kind of
helped with the the framework so I was
gonna use and the the way I was writing
this paper enterpreneurship is also big
at MIT so that's why I even wants to be
an entrepreneur after a 10-year career
in finance so I think all of those
things kind of work together to to help
me produce this independent study I do
think however it's you know it's it's
just yes for me it was MIT but for
anyone else it could be anything right
it's just a matter of figuring out what
you have in your own ecosystem and then
using that to your advantage
also in addition to being Aslam
negative fellow which is Legatum is a
center here and my MIT for
entrepreneurship and development and it
supports 20 fellows per year that wants
to work in the developing world after
graduation so it's everybody from PhDs
in engineering to you know undergraduate
and so I came here through a scholarship
from the Legatum Foundation so it helped
me so I knew coming in that I wanted to
be an entrepreneur in the developing
world after Sloane so you know and my
startup idea is in agriculture so it
kind of you know it's another part of
what what created this independent study
I knew some people that I interviewed in
the you know that I interviewed some
stakeholders that I interviewed truly
got'em and then approaching them as Alec
Adam fellow it kind of made sense that I
was doing this you know agriculture
paper so it kind of helped me you know
talk to people that I probably would
never had time reaching out to Angela
also brought in her contacts for people
that I needed to interview so that was
helpful as well and and the name MIT was
helpful as well so I guess to kind of
link back to the ecosystem right so
reaching out to someone is saying hey
I'm a student at MIT and I'm studying
this topic was I think helpful for
people to open up their doors and and
resources and such
I just came from a conference last week
after graduation I went straight to a
conference at the World Bank and it's
just this I think everybody is kind of
questioning this idea of does technology
actually is technology a good solution
and if so how should we be using it and
how do we really get this rural
communities to to prosper you know and
there's a lot actually in between
farming seasons right so you know
farming season could be just three
months or you know and then you add the
the preparation time which is another
couple of months and then you know
farmers are going from cycle to cycle
and not really their conditions are not
really improving
so people are questioning why that it
that is happening and what do we what we
need to do more off or less off so I
think that you know it's an exciting
sector because I think that the whole
world is well worried about food
security the whole world is worried
about climate change which is linked to
agriculture so I think you know it's a
hot topic it's just people need to
figure out everybody needs to be on
board in terms of figuring out what
needs to be done because on one hand you
have people that are investing in more
production of food so that we have food
security but then is that food
distributed equally you know that that
remains to be seen and then on the other
hand you know there's all this talk
about climate change and and what
farmers should be doing or not be doing
and they're all these technologies that
people are coming up with but are they
being co-created with the communities
probably not and so uptake of those
technologies is slower than people think
so there's the oldest you know topics oh
there's this loose ends that need to be
figured out and I think that's why it's
exciting for me to to you know to be in
and hopefully I can figure out a small
part of it